the U.S President Joe Biden is heading
towards Britain for talks with prime
minister Rishi sunak they expected to
discuss the latest developments in the
war in Ukraine let's go to Kimberly
hawkitt our White House correspondent
given the UK prime minister as one of
the critics of Biden's recent decision
to supply cluster bombs to Ukraine this
might make for quite an awkward visit
yeah there's no question that this is
going to be a difficult conversation for
the U.S president he is set to leave his
beach home momentarily where he will be
traveling to the United Kingdom he will
be having his sixth meeting with the UK
prime minister but it will be an
uncomfortable one compared to some of
those previous meetings given the fact
that the U.S president has gone ahead
even overriding U.S law to approve
cluster Munitions for use in Ukraine
this is not just unpopular with the UK
prime minister but also with Germany
with Spain and of course a human rights
groups and even members of the
president's own Democratic party given
the fact that it's shown to be
disproportionately adverse to civilians
and and harm civilians long after
conflicts end and so that is the reason
for the opposition still the problem for
the U.S president is that he made a
commitment to Ukraine that the United
States would support it for the long
haul and the problem is is that the
United States has run out of
conventional weaponry and there simply
is a shortage and so that is the
explanation he is going to give to the
UK prime minister but certainly this is
one that may not sit well so this is
really a pre-meeting if you will in
advance of a broader meeting that of
course will take place with NATO leaders
in Lithuania in the coming days yeah so
tell us a little more about Biden's
plans and that NATO Summit what more are
we expecting
yeah well even before the NATO Summit on
the heels of that meeting with Rishi
sunak there will be a meeting with King
Charles that will happen immediately
after and this is also going to be very
interesting because uh the the U.S
president is going to have to delicately
balance with King Charles who typically
has an apolitical role the issue of
climate change which of course is very
important to the king and so how they
will discuss that in terms of that
apolitical role is going to be watched
very closely then the president will
travel to Lithuania where a couple of
issues are going to be at the Forefront
of course Ukraine the U.S president is
going to be trying to get more support
for weapons for Ukraine support from
those leaders and again those
uncomfortable conversations about
cluster bombs as well there is also
going to be some uh lobbying for the
case for Sweden to join the NATO
alliance and also uh questions about
whether or not there's a pathway for
Ukraine itself to join the alliance so
these are all going to be very delicate
conversations that will be taking place
both formally and on the sidelines and
we should also point out that after that
the U.S president will be traveling for
yet another Summit the first of its kind
for the Biden Administration he'll be
traveling to Helsinki in Finland where
he will be meeting with the leaders of
the Nordic countries there they'll be
having a summit where they'll be talking
about the concerns of Russia and China
and their growing influence in the
Arctic regions
thank you for that our White House
correspondent Kimberly Hulk up there